[موسيقى]
قدم العديد من افلام الرعب والمغامرات
والكوميديا ثم اصبح احدا نجوم هوليود
الاكثر شهره لكن قله من يرون الجانب
المظلم في مسيرته والتجارب المريره التي
عاشها قبل ان يصبح راين رونالدو البطل
الخارق على الشاشه الكبيره فما قصته
ولد راين رونالدو عام
1976 في كندا وهو الاصغر بين اربعه اطفال
كان والده تاجرا للمواد الغذائيه في مكانه
والدته بائعه اما طفولته فلم تترك ذكريات
جميله حيث عانى من قسوه والده وغالبا ما
احطت به دوامات الخوف من الفشل وعندما
حاول الاتجاه الى الدراما اثناء مرحله
الدراسه الثانويه تعرض ايضا لاخفاقات
كبيره ومع ذلك حصل على دور في المسلسل
التلفزيوني هل صعد الذي سمي لاحقا فيفتين
باجر 150 دولار يوميا وبالنسبه للشاب ريان
كانت تلك الكثرى بعد انتهاء المسلسل عاد
الى فرانكفورد حيث لاعبه في سلسله من
الافلام التلفزيونيه المنسيه في ما كان
يعمل بتوصيل الصحف ولانه لم يكن مولعا
بالتمثيل تخلى عنه حيث عمل لعامين بمتجر
ثم بمطعم قبل ان يقنعه صديقه المغني
كريسمارتن بالعوده والانتقال الى لوس
انجلوس لكن الحياه هناك لم تكن ورديه قدم
راين دور بردج في فيلم توجايز اجيرل اند
ذا بيتزا بلاي وهو العمل الذي تعرض
للانتقاد الكثير ولم يحقق النجاح المنشود
مع ذلك تم تجديد له في موسم ثاني فحقق
نجاحا طفيفا ما هذا لرايا العمل في ادوار
سينمائيه جديده مثل المشاركه في فيلم
الرعب ذا امتي ذا هاله ثم ظهر في فيلم
الحركه والمغامره اكس من اوريجينز ولفرين
وقدم عرضا جيدا في فيلم ذا بروبوزال مع
ساندرا بلوك ثم حصد بعض النجاح عام 2010
بعد عرض فيلم بيرد ثم اظهر مهارات مميزه
في الكوميديا بفيلم ذا شينجا ربما
وقرايا بالفعل طعم النجاح لكنه واجه
الكثير من الاخفاقات ووجد نفسه غارقا في
ادمان المخدرات ما جعل من حياته كابوسا
كبيرا فطالما استيقظ من نومه بسبب القلق
والتفكير في المستقبل والاكتئاب عان احد
عشر عاما من الشعور بخيبه الامل تلقى
خلالها نحو سبع واربعين رساله ترفض قبل ان
يحظى بفرصه الظهور بشخصيه خارقه في الفيلم
عام 2016 الذي غير حياته حصل رايا بفضل
دوره في فيلم ذا بول اعلى جائزه جولدن
جلوب خلال مسيرته الحافله قدم رينز اكثر
من 62 عملا وظهر في العديد من الافلام
الناجحه مثل ذلك
العديد من الجوائز الفني ليصبح اكثر
الممثلين شعبيتا سواء في هوليوود او على
شبكه نتفليكس مع ثروه تقدر ب 150 مليون
دولار كما ان مسيرته اصبحت قصه ملهمه
للكثير من اليائسين حول العالم
[موسيقى]